Christina Applegate offers support to
Selena Gomez I think it was really
healing for me to see that and get it
out from one former Child Star to
another I'm so happy
no on the heels of Selena's intimate
documentary I'm immediately historically
crying because it hurts like everything
which in part Chronicles her journey
with lupus Christine is sharing more
about living with Ms recently posting
this pic of walking sticks she says it
become part of her new normal I I just
always feel better when I have answers
and the dead to me stars applauding
Selena's decision to get candid in a
since deleted tweet Christina says she
watched Selena's Doc and writes quote
from one immunocompromise to another I'm
here EXO Ms and lupus are baby sisters
from other mothers and a dad who owns a
weird truck good on you kid for opening
your life to those that need an eye open
it was the best thing that ever happened
yes in a weird way I feel like it is
it's a time capsule of a period of my
life where I look back and I actually
feel bad for that version of myself I
think my advice is to not be afraid and
I think that's just who I am while the
Tweet is no longer around with no
explanation from Christina we're
assuming the sentiment remains I'm gonna
say I'm here eight years later I'm good
I'm good I'm tired but I'm good before
Christina's Ms diagnosis she publicly
battled breast cancer you are constantly
you have a daily reminder of everything
that you've gone through you know fast
forward to 2022 she's getting candid
about filming the third and final season
of dead to me I think we should have
Outlaw names should we telling the New
York Times she struggled walking down
the stairs of her trailer and was taken
to set in a wheelchair
it's too late no it's not too late there
is always a way out as co-star James
Marsden tells it Christina's a fighter
Nothing's Gonna Keep Her down and she's
going to battle and fight through
anything and and um I just I admire her
as a person as just a compassionate
wonderful human being who's fun to work
with anything that life will throw at
her she will just she'll figure out a
way to not let it keep her down and
she's and she's doing exactly that and
it's really really inspiring to see
um but but honestly no surprise to me
because that is who she is as a
character and as as a human being
[Music]
foreign
[Music]